hey you've got to see this fox host
Jesse Waters tried to confront a satanic
temple leader Lucian Graves who we've
had on the program before and it went
really really really poorly
um Jesse Waters and others on Fox News
love to go after the satanic temple and
the satanic temple you know some people
say the satanic temp temple is a
satirical religion but the truth is it's
really no more or less satirical than
any other religion and this is sort of
the point that you don't get to say well
the satanic temple it's not like
Christianity no it actually kind of is
and so Jesse Waters brings on Lucian
Graves and he seems to think that he's
going to steamroll him and he doesn't
and it's very very interesting take a
look at this
well we still have some questions so
let's ask the satanic temple
spokesperson Lucian Greaves all right
first of all Lucian Grieves it's Lucian
Graves it's not a particularly difficult
name to say Lucian if Satan is evil I
thought nice to meet you too if Satan's
evil why should kids be in an evil Club
well obviously we don't view Satan as
evil and it really doesn't matter to us
what your mythology is surrounding Satan
you need to ask yourself if your
distaste over us identifying as Satanist
is strong enough that you would abandon
the principles of free speech and
religious liberty I always thought Satan
was like sex you know like when you're
18 Satan sex do your thing but I don't
know if I would want Satan in schools
you understand how parents feel right
well parents can feel that way and many
parents feel similarly about Evangelical
after-school clubs and in fact we put
our club in place to offer an
alternative against Evangel an
Evangelical Club that's explicitly
designed to convert children and get
them to proselytize to other kids so if
parents don't want to send their kids to
an after-school Satan Club they can send
them to an Evangelical Club there's
other religious clubs really I think the
controversy just evades the issue as to
whether or not we're willing to allow
government functionaries at school
boards or whatever to Simply shut down
somebody's religious liberty or Free
Speech because they don't like it so
you're kind of doing it to tweak the
system I get it what are these tenets of
Satanism can you enlighten me
yeah I think the tenants are very
pro-social they're almost Universal I
would think and and I think as time goes
on we'll kind of converge on a consensus
morality but as but we don't have to I
mean people we're not looking to convert
people into Satanism we're not even
teaching children about Satanism and
classes well give me a tenant
one should strive to act with compassion
and empathy with it to All Creatures
within reason
that sounds fun all right
might like it yeah maybe I don't know
about all that dude are you married by
the way
uh no I'm not no okay I just I was just
wondering all right so you're probably
gonna go to hell right
I I don't believe in hell we're a
non-theistic religious group all right I
thought maybe you wanted to go to hell
Ida what do I know I need to learn more
about like a better party than Heaven
Fox News promoted this as a grilling of
Lucian Graves that Jesse Waters really
grilled him
the one substantive point that came up
which is Lucian explaining how others
should be treated based on the satanic
Temple's view Jesse agreed with and then
he switched to are you married I guess
to just ridicule him and based on I
don't even know and say no of course you
couldn't find a wife or husband who
knows you know I mean you have one place
where all the Sexes kind of go after
they live a
celebrate an interesting life how am I
might might be okay all right we gotta
go
um I'm probably gonna butcher your name
again
almost had it thank you very much have a
great night yeah so Fox News promotes
that as a grilling and really the
interesting thing here is every time
that the satanic temple stuff comes up
and again my view is I'm not a satanic
temple member and I'm not Christian but
I don't really see any difference and
the condescension from and that there's
many Christians that have interviewed
Lucian The condescension about your
religion it's it's nothing like ours
like our our thing is real your thing
isn't real it's either evil or it's a
parody and a joke
substantively speaking and it very
importantly in the eyes of the law and
this applies to after school programs as
well there really is not a distinction
now I I do think that where you would
start to go over a line is if there is a
a religious group
um and they want to have an after-school
program and there's they're like openly
advocating for violence or murder and by
the way I mean what's crazy is there are
Evangelical churches recently that have
advocated for violence against people
who support for example abortion being
legal so like it actually happens and
they don't get in trouble but if things
were sensible I could see arguing that a
particular religion maybe shouldn't be
allowed to have an after-school group if
it could be proven that they're really
just advocating for physical violence
and they're teaching kids to you know go
out and attack people or something like
that
beyond that to pass these moral
judgments or to create tears of religion
based solely on the number of followers
that they have and certainly there are
more Christians than Satanic Temple
members really misses the point of the
framework of how this country is
organized and Jesse Waters and people
like him
seemed from a starting point assume that
of course Christianity is in a different
category than the satanic temple when it
really isn't and so Fox News promoted
that as a grilling I didn't see much of
a grilling let me know your thoughts
make sure you're subscribed to our
YouTube channel there are more than
three million of you who watch our Clips
but don't subscribe my request is hit
that subscribe button it's free and it
really helps us
one of our sponsors today is fume fume
is on a mission to accelerate Humanity's
breakup from the bad habits that consume
far too many of us including ones that
harm our health fume is a natural
diffusive device that uses plants and
Behavioral Science to trade out your
negative habit for a positive one fume
is not a vape it's a non-electronic
device designed to transform your
negative habits instead of PODS filled
with potentially harmful chemicals like
a vape fumuses cores infused with plants
like peppermint and cinnamon for
delicious natural flavors fumes new
version 2 model is Snappy and tactile
with an adjustable airflow dial and a
magnetic end cap that's fun to fidget
with it's fume's goal to make switching
easy or even enjoyable they have
thousands of five star reviews from
people just like you who have
successfully switched when other
Solutions didn't work head to trifum.com
and use the code Pacman to get 10 off
today when you get the journey pack
which comes with three unique flavors
and the new version to fume the link is
down below